gut es war in erster Linie natürlich
auch eine Protestwahl was der AFD dazu
Bude gekommen ist im Westen stand sie
auch schon mal 2016 ganz gut da in
Rheinland-Pfalz und Baden-Württemberg
sogar noch besser als jetzt in
Niedersachsen aber die Hochburgen die
bleiben natürlich in Ostdeutschland die
AFD hat ihr Wahlergebnis gegenüber dem
Jahr 2017 nahezu verdoppelt 10,9% waren
es gestern Abend das gilt als Erfolg und
der wurde in der AFD ja auch
entsprechend gefeiert und wir wollen
jetzt in einem Interview herausbekommen
was man die Gründe und was fängt die AFD
vor allem in diesem Wahlerfolg an und
bei mir ist Beatrix von Storch die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der AFD im Bundestag Frau von Storch man
kann ja sagen die AFD ist eine Krisen
Gewinnerin wir haben eine veritable
Krise und sie haben gewonnen sie haben
in Niedersachsen mächtig zugelegt fühlen
Sie sich in dieser Rolle der
krisengewinnerin wohl ja die AFD hat
Angebote gemacht wie diese Krise zu
verhindern gewesen wäre bzw wie man sie
jetzt reduzieren kann in erster Linie
ging es um Inflation und um
Energiesicherheit und um Energiepreise
und in dem Bereich macht die AFD das
einzige vernünftige Angebot und die
Menschen im Land wissen das wir brauchen
einen breiten Energie-Mix wir brauchen
deutsche Kohle wir brauchen deutsche
Kernkraft und wir brauchen natürlich
möglichst auch Gas wir brauchen gerne
auch erneuerbare Energien wir brauchen
alle einheimischen Energieträger die wir
fördern müssen und das ist das einzige
vernünftige dieses Angebot haben wir
klar und vor allen Dingen glaubwürdig
gemacht kein Mensch glaubt Herrn Lindner
dass er das auch möchte kein Mensch
glaubt Herrn Merz dass sie das auch
möchten denn wenn Sie das tatsächlich
für das Überleben unserer Wirtschaft und
die Menschen für wichtig erachten würden
dann könnten sie es durchsetzen es gibt
für die Verlängerung der Kernkraftwerke
eine Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag
selbstverständlich nicht mit den roten
und mit den Grünen gut sie haben jetzt
Punkte angesprochen im Wahlkampf hat man
aber von der AFD eigentlich fast CO2
andere Argumente gehört die Sanktionen
gegen Russland aufzuheben und nordstream
2 wieder und eins wieder zu öffnen diese
beiden Gasleitungen sind geöffnet nur an
den falschen Stellen ich sag mal weder
Sanktionen noch nordstream öffnen wird
es geben wie wollen Sie jetzt mit dieser
mit diesen Forderungen umgehen ja wir
stellen einfach fest dass wir ohne das
russische Gas tatsächlich nicht
auskommen und die Menschen sind
verzweifelt in diesem Land weil sie
nicht mehr wissen ob sie über den Winter
kommen wir haben ein Wirtschaftsminister
der auf gutes Wetter hofft und denkt
dann haben wir vielleicht eine Chance
über den Winter zu kommen das heißt sie
haben überhaupt gar kein Angebot und
unseres ist klar in der größten
Energiekrise dieses Landes dass dieses
Land jemals gesehen hat seit dem Krieg
kann man doch laufende Kernkraftwerke
nicht abstellen und die einzigen die das
glaubwürdig vertreten sind wir und die
Russland Sanktionen haben zu gar nichts
geführt außer dass es den Russen besser
geht als vorher und uns schlechter als
vorher das heißt die Sanktionen Schaden
uns und nicht denen dass es vollkommen
ab ja gut also das behaupten sie jetzt
das den Russen besser und schlechter
geht dafür gibt es eigentlich keine
Beweise aber sollten wir uns wirklich
weiterhin energiemäßig von einem
Kriegsverbrecher abhängig machen wir
sollten uns und das ist genau das
Programm der AFD wir sollten uns
möglichst unabhängig machen in der von
der Energiesicherheit von allen
möglichen Ländern dieser Welt möglichst
viel eigene Energie erzeugen vollkommen
richtig die einzigen die das wollen das
ist die AFD uns abhängig gemacht von
russischem Gas das sind die Regierung
vor uns gewesen jetzt auch noch den
Russen der uns die Energie liefert von
der wir abhängig sind mit seinem Sohn zu
bedrohen und sich dann zu wundern dass
er auch nicht liefert muss man nicht
wirklich erwarten das heißt das zentrale
für die Wirtschaftsstandort und für die
Menschen in diesem Land ist dass wir
Energiesicherheit möglichst in
Deutschland herstellen das bedeutet
Verlängerung der Laufzeiten der
Kernkraftwerke Einsteigen in die
Kohlekraft bzw Wiedereröffnung der der
Kohlekraftwerke und wir müssen anfangen
Fracking zu prüfen wir müssen versuchen
uns von allen in der Welt unabhängig zu
machen von den Russen genauso wie von
Aserbaidschan oder Kata gut
auf jeden Fall war der Überfall auf die
Ukraine der Brandbeschleuniger der Krise
sie haben Recht schon vorher gab es ja
da Ursachen die sich jetzt auch
auswirken was passiert denn mit der AFD
wenn die Krise relativ glimpflich
verläuft wenn ich das passiert was viele
befürchten wenn wir einigermaßen gut
über den Winter kommen wissen sie das
ist unser politisches Angebot das
Angebot der Opposition ist es auf die
Fehler der Regierung zu zeigen und
alternative Angebote zu machen und mit
diesen Alternativen angeboten kämen wir
besser durch die Krise deswegen machen
wir Sie und deswegen ist es wichtig da
dran zu bleiben wir hoffen dass die
Regierung auf den Pfad der Tugenden
zurückkehrt und unsere unsere unser
Programm umsetzt das wäre ein echter
Mehrgewinn für die Menschen in diesem
Land dann kommen wir vielleicht besser
durch den Winter und haben nicht die
Sorgen die existenziellen Sorgen die die
Menschen jetzt berechtigterweise haben
eine letzte Frage noch die AFD hat einen
Wahlerfolg eingefahren was machen Sie
mit diesem Wahlerfolg niemand will mit
ihnen koalieren Bündnisse schließen was
machen sie damit
wir bieten an dass es in diesem Land
eine Mehrheit beispielsweise gibt für
die Verlängerung der Kernkraftwerke in
der größten Energiekrise die dieses Land
jemals gesehen haben
das ist die Unglaubwürdigkeit von Herrn
März beispielsweise und von Herrn
Lindner den eben kein Mensch glaubt dass
sie wirklich es um dies wohl der
Menschen geht in diesem Land denn dann
würden sie die Mehrheit nutzen die da
ist um Energiesicherheit herzustellen
liegt aber nicht an der AFD dass sie das
nicht nutzen dieses Angebot dass sie ihn
machen das liegt an CDU und FDP und
dafür sind wir auch beide ordentlich
abgestraft worden soweit Beatrix von
Storch hier bei Phoenix bedanke mich für
das Gespräch so kleiner Hinweis noch
gegen 12 Uhr kommt der Bundessprecher
Tino kupala zu uns um 13 Uhr die
Pressekonferenz der AFD hier in einem
Berliner Hotel und um diese Termine
herum werden wir auch weiter Analysen
liefern zum Abschneiden der AFD gestern
bei der Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen
damit zurück zu Stefan Kulle nach Bonn